y vimos que sí tenemos una corriente con
un flujo en línea recta laminar la ley
de pues ella nos dice cuánto volumen por
tiempo va a fluir a través de la tubería
pero como sabemos que tenemos un buen
flujo laminar que es lo que determina
cuando esto se vuelve caótico cuando
empiezan a atravesarse estas capas de
fluido como sabemos que van a
ocasionarse estos vórtices cuando sucede
esto pues resulta que hay una forma de
predecirlo aunque es bastante difícil es
difícil predecir cuándo va a empezar a
volverse caótico esto pero una vez que
sabemos que las cosas van a ponerse
turbulentas es aún más difícil tratar de
describir el comportamiento que va a
tener típicamente tenemos que usar
simulaciones por computadora para hacer
esto en lugar de cálculos analíticos
pero hay un número que llamamos el
número de reynolds lo que hace este
número es ayudarnos a predecir cuáles
aquella velocidad crítica la que si
llegamos a superar y el flujo va a una
velocidad mayor que ésta comienza a
darse la turbulencia la forma de hacerlo
es tomar este número de reynolds que le
llamamos r mayúscula la multiplicamos
por la viscosidad esta letra griega eta
que usamos para describir la viscosidad
de un líquido la dividimos entre 2
multiplicado por la densidad del fluido
y lo multiplicamos por el radio del tubo
esto nos da la velocidad en la que se
espera haya turbulencia si medimos el
número de reynolds para darnos una idea
la sangre y esto sale a colación cuando
hablamos del flujo sanguíneo en la aorta
cuando hay preocupación de que pueda
darse turbulencia en la corriente
sanguínea para la sangre el número de
reynolds es de 2000 y esto no tiene
unidades no tiene dimensiones aquí todas
las unidades se cancelan el número de
reynolds es una cantidad dimensional
por lo que el conocer el número de
reinos nos ayuda a predecir la primera
velocidad en la que podrá darse
turbulencia en donde podemos esperar que
la ley de pase y no nos dé una
descripción razonable de el flujo del
fluido